[Music]
[Music]
and so would you be able to describe
what supersymmetry theory is or what
super sevens with the symmetrical
particles could be so we have this
theory of how matter is built up out of
elementary particles things like the
electron and then the electrons form
atoms because they make clouds around
nuclei and inside the nucleus you have
things called protons and neutrons but
which are not actually elementary
particles themselves they contain more
elementary things called quarks so these
quarks electrons
those are the fundamental constituents
of matter so the theory of supersymmetry
postulates that in addition to these
particles which we've already discovered
there's a whole bunch of what I would
call sibling particles which have the
same internal properties like for
example electric charge so there would
be a supersymmetric partner of the
electron let's call it thus electron
which would have negative charge just
like the electron does but there's a
couple of very important differences one
is that it would weigh a lot more much
heavier mass and the other thing is that
it does not spin so all the elementary
particles that we know of with one
exception that I come back to they all
turn around on their axes are about like
spinning tops electron does for example
the photon the particle of light that
twists around as well but the
supersymmetric partner of the electron
would not and there would also be a
supersymmetric partner of the photon the
particle of light which would turn
around in a different way from the way
the photon does so as I said according
to supersymmetry all the known particles
have these sibling particles same
internal poverty same interactions if
you like about different mass and
different ways of spinning and why the
need to posit these super stretchable
particles so the idea of supersymmetry
arose from attempts to try to unify all
the particles into a more more simple
picture and so supersymmetry was
originally suggested back in the 1970s
and then as time went on people thought
well actually you know that could be
useful for various things so for example
supersymmetry could help us understand
why particles have the masses that they
do and why they don't weigh much more
for example
the lightest supersymmetric particle is
probably stable and it could be around
us today in the universe as some sort of
invisible dark matter particle as we
call it so little parentheses so the
astronomers the astrophysicists tell us
that in galaxies in addition to the
visible matter in stars there must be a
whole bunch of invisible stuff which
provides additional gravitational force
which holds the galaxies together and
that additional force could be produced
by these heavy
supersymmetric particles and so how do
you go about doing this research what
evidence can you look for
so there's various different ways in
which you could look for supersymmetric
particles so you could imagine producing
them in laboratory experiment so one of
the things that we're doing in
experiments at CERN at the Large Hadron
Collider so there we bang protons
together at the highest possible
energies the highest possible rates look
to see what comes out and it's possible
that pairs of supersymmetric particles
would come out or more generally pairs
of dark matter particles another way in
which you could look the supersymmetric
particles is no the suggestion is that
there were these dark matter particles
flying around in the galaxies all the
time in particular right here they're
flattened they're flying past us and
every once in a while one of those dark
matter particles will hit a piece of
regular matter and it will leave behind
some energy and so people are designing
very sensitive detectors which can pick
up this very small amount of energy
that's deposited when one of these dark
matter particles comes through another
thing which you can do is while if
they're these dark matter particles
flying around in our galaxy every once
in a while a pair of them may collide
and if they do then the energy will be
converted into regular particles and
then you can look for particular types
of conventional particles in the cosmic
rays to see whether there's any evidence
there of these annihilations of these
dark matter particles and do you think
that one of these experiments will be
more fruitful than others are you
working on all of these so I I'm working
on all of them at the same time because
these different experiments tell you
different things about where the
supersymmetric particles might be how
heavy they might be and how strongly
they can interact so so it's interesting
to push in these various different
directions and eventually maybe by no
combining all these results then we may
get some better idea of what
supersymmetry looks like
basically about 95% of the universe we
don't understand and we we use this term
the dart universe to describe that part
of the universe the other 5% is the
stuff that you and I are made up of and
the earth and the moon and the Sun and
and everything you can see this other
95% we call it dark because it's
mysterious and we don't understand it
and there are two entities on the dark
side there's something that we call dark
matter that's about a quarter of the
universe and then something that we're
gonna call dark energy which is about
75% of the universe so I should say you
know this is all theory that I've talkin
about this dark matter and dark energy
these are names that we use to describe
entities that we believe are there but
we have no direct proof of the existence
of a dark matter particle and we really
have no understanding of where this
additional energy source of the universe
has come from so one good theory to
explain the Dark Matter particle is
something called supersymmetric theories
which comes from particle physics but
the simplest supersymmetric theories
model suggests that the Large Hadron
Collider in CERN should have already
created some of these dark matter
particles and so that's putting that
theory into some level of trouble I mean
it's a very flexible theory so it's not
not dead in the water yet but I think
over the next ten years I'm gonna say 20
years if the particle physicists don't
discover a Dark Matter particle then I
will start getting increasingly worried
about as astronomers we need this this
Dark Matter component in our universe to
understand the observations that we make
and as I say all the tests I've done of
Einstein's theory of general teams so
far I've come back drop I mean it is the
best test in theory that we have it and
it works beautifully your your sat-nav
wouldn't work if you didn't understand
or what you don't have to understand it
but if engineers and scientists didn't
understand Einstein's theory of general
relativity your sat-nav wouldn't work so
we know this theory works well but maybe
it works differently in different parts
of the universe these are things that we
can test I think it probably will work
fine what we can test it and that's
important thing so you're not taken in
by the sort of grand theory of
supersymmetry and so supersymmetry has
lots of elegance so there are three
force it there are four forces in the
universe there's gravity which is sort
of off on one side and then we have the
electromagnetic strong and weak forces
and supersymmetry allows you to
understand how those three forces kind
of work together power back in the in
the very hot environments the early
universe right after the Big Bang how
those three would have been very similar
and that gives us a good understanding
of where those horses are coming from
and then one can go to the next step of
how do we unite gravity in as well so
it's a beautifully elegant theory and I
think that's why people have spent so
much time working on it I like the
theory because it gives me a good
theoretical grounding for what the Dark
Matter particle will be which is you
know what I'm particularly interested in
and it's genuinely disappointing that it
hasn't been realized at CERN yet are we
exciting I used to work at CERN and I
still go out and work there a lot so I
work on their data and I work on
mathematical models of particle physics
and how and forces and the early
universe and my area of work is really
between the data and theory trying to
inform one by the other and sort of back
things back and forwards and up until
last year I spent all my career work
working on the supersymmetry theory
which is a theory of particle physics
and but we thought that the Large Hadron
Collider experiment at CERN was going to
produce particles predicted new
particles predicted by the supersymmetry
theory and it hasn't there's this hope
hasn't panned out so I've kind of
shifted what what I'm working on but the
supersymmetry theory was beautiful to
work on for a while it was it had very
lofty ideals it it was a it was a bridge
to theories of everything
like mathematical theories of all
particles and forces which tried to
explain everything about our universe so
you know dark matter how forces work
what what women made of you know what
light is everything but you the problem
with them was you had to make quite a
lot of assumptions to to predict just a
few things that you could measure and
test in an experiment and then we looked
in the experiment and they weren't there
so yeah so I had to rethink last year
and now I'm working in a different mode
I'm looking at the data and looking for
glitches so we predict with the standard
model of particle physics that's the
current knowledge that we have we
predict how the data should look from
the collisions between two protons at
CERN at high energies and we look for
cases where the the model disagrees the
prediction disagrees with what's what
scene and then for that that for me is
an opportunity so then we we jump on
that and try and explain it but explain
it in a very simple way we kind of just
bung in an extra force or an extra
particle that would explain the what
scene and then we do some proper
phenomenology so we try and suggest
other ways in which it may be tested we
first of all checked that it's
consistent with all other data and then
suggest other ways you can save the data
to look for these new particles or
forces and then you know go one step
further in the theoretical direction so
this is more we call it bottom-up
science working from the data and where
you've got really solid foundation and
you think you know what's going on and
then making hypotheses away from that so
I'm enjoying this new way of working it
certainly quite different to the
previous way where you try and solve
everything
and make loads of assumptions that's
what that we called top-down you know
it's like you start from pure thought
thoughts and then try and get to
very mental observations but for me
anyway that that that approach hasn't
panned out so you know I'm trying a new
approach and it's and it's a lot of fun
so this change in starting from the data
rather than theory does this mean that
you've sort of given up hope of finding
supersymmetrical particle okay so if the
work still focused on supersymmetry are
you that's just a belief you have but
you're kind of like no I okay so looking
at my own work at the moment the way the
way I answer this question is the way
for me to make progress right now
is not to work on supersymmetry and the
reason is because we know from the data
that the Large Hadron Collider has seen
already that in the next few years
there's not going to be a big discovery
of secret supersymmetric particles
otherwise we would have seen small
fluctuations and the data already so in
the next year is for me that's not
whether discovery is going to be so I'm
looking elsewhere but still you know you
can't help in your heart of hearts
believe in this beautiful theory which
explains a really important fact that we
otherwise don't understand
and that fact is why is the Higgs boson
so light so if you do calculations on
Higgs bosons and they're they're
affected by quantum fluctuations the
little the seething of space-time in
terms of other particles and they're
they're special in that they fill those
fluctuations extremely sensitively and
if you do back-of-the-envelope
calculations those fluctuations should
increase its mass by something like a
billion billion times more than it then
it's been measured to be so this this is
a puzzle that we don't understand with
our current theory it's not explained
why is the Higgs boson so light and how
is it able to stay so light with these
quantum fluctuations supersymmetry
explains this it doesn't mean it's the
only that doesn't mean it's the only
explanation but the other ones don't
work or you know we haven't really found
a decent of the one so that's why we
were so
keen on it and why we thought we might
be able to find
supersymmetric particles as a signal
that the theory was right at the Large
Hadron Collider so you know if in I
don't know five or ten years time some
signals start appearing from the data of
course I'm going to jump back right back
on it right but for the moment I think
in terms of progress it's it's more
fruitful for me personally to look
elsewhere
so supersymmetry as far as we can tell
is an essential feature of this theory
called string theory which is for my
mind the only serious candidate we have
for an all-encompassing theory of
everything so I think if we found
evidence for supersymmetry then the next
item on the agenda would be to try to
find some sort of positive evidence for
string theory one way or another but
that looks pretty tough string theory is
trying to explain what we are made of
how the universe works at the most
fundamental level what are the basic
ingredients what are the forces between
particles how did the universe come to
be how does a black hole work what is
the future of the universe holds for us
all the deep questions that everybody
wants to know it's kind of like yeah of
course I want to know that does this
field have anything to say about that
and indeed string theory has begin has
begun to offer us some some context into
in terms of which we can begin to answer
these deep questions for example we have
learned that the the matter in the
universe is all unified into one that
unity is quite amazing and that's what's
one of the elegant things which at once
sounds philosophical at the same time is
a unifying principle of explaining all
of physics so while one must might think
that all this sounds like very just
wishful thinking about aesthetic this
has come out to be real in the context
of string theory and be realized so so
we're fortunate to be having such a
structure where it potentially explains
everything around us in terms of this
unifying picture in terms of how the
matter all comes together how the forces
get unified and how
comes to describe the geometry of space
and time how does in Stein's theory fit
with quantum mechanics how do the black
holes come to the picture how'd the Big
Bang work how what's going to happen in
the future all them together from the
smallest to the biggest from how forces
work to how everything microscopically
behaves so what kind of significance all
consequences to string theory lead why
should we care about strong string
theory today well it is the reason we
care about string theories that we
believe in Stein had the correct
description of gravity which is a
geometric picture of how gravity works
by the curvature of space and time on
the other hand we also know at the
microscopic level the tiniest level
quantum mechanics is important how the
atoms work since we know quantum
mechanics is a fact of life in the real
in the in the real world in the
microscopic regime and Einstein's theory
seems to be correct in a macroscopic
description of gravitational forces well
if you take Einstein's theory and take
it to the extreme of smaller and smaller
shorter and shorter microscopic
descriptions of it you better have a
consistent theory with quantum mechanics
and there is no other framework today
which is consistent with Einstein's
theory and quantum mechanics at the same
time string theory is the only candidate
we have which combines Einstein's theory
with quantum mechanics in a consistent
framework and how is it that it brings
about that gap between Einstein's theory
and content it is actually one of the
miracles we don't understand how it does
it what we found is that if you study
these vibrating strings which are these
excitations that we have one of their
modes one of the little modes at least
string F which is very tiny strings
turns out to have exactly the same
properties as a as mediating
gravitational force that is that
exchange of this little thing between
other particles mediates gravitational
force between them why it had to have
this property is not clear but it turned
out that this this theory just does it
and so many things in string theory we
don't understand why it works and it's
really magical and part of the reason we
believe in it is that nobody put it in
by hand it's not like if somebody says
you know what I'm bored I want to put
this thing in so let me just change my
theory so that's gravity in it no people
studies started studying string here and
they say oh there's gravity in this I
where did that come from so it gives
more credibility to the theory it's kind
of brings out things we want to have
without actually putting it in so we
believe that's one of the beautiful
aspects of string theory this magical
property that things that you get out of
it are more than what you put in capture
your imagination well st. Erie certainly
captured all our imaginations when it
was formulated I was remember listening
in CERN theory lecture room to when the
first
animala cancellation was discovered in
string theory this was 1984 and everyone
was thinking you know within two three
years we'll everything will be sorted
out well that was what was it over 34 35
35 36 years ago that's because it has
turned out to be much more difficult
than people thought and no the idea was
that the strings themselves their
dynamics create the space time in which
the strings move but that has proved too
ambitious a construction so currently
all of string theory is formulated in a
flat space-time background in Minkowski
space-time which means that the real
dynamics of what string theory could
tell you we still don't know about it's
just too difficult it's already very
very difficult at this stage and the
full string theory nobody really even
knows what string theory is that's what
you know I know some real string
theorists and that's what they tell me
that it's hard to even formulate what is
string theory so in a sense I guess we
are lucky that we have hit upon
something like that which has got such
depth and complexity but at the same
time
progress is frustratingly slow but then
that's really because we are impatient
if you look at the history of science
most things took you know century to
work out and why do you expect that in
35 years we'll have the answers so I
think we should give string theory more
time and string theory is more time but
they should perhaps also be a bit modest
and not claim that they're going to
solve everything in three years
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institutes of
arson ideas at IAI TV
you